[Music]
one of the biggest storylines on The
Voice this season is Jack Casady because
he is David Cassidy's nephew and Shirley
Jones's grandson but Monday night Jack's
dream hangs in the balance as Alicia
Keys passed to decide who stays on her
team and who has to go
[Applause]
Jack came in and it wasn't until he lets
his voice break and go wide open that
you're like whoa Jack's gonna win this
one hunter you have to make a record I
mean my god your voice is so beautiful I
undertook this for me hands down
Jack's sing off for survival against
Hunter draws mixed opinions from Adam
Gwen and Blake
but are they luring Alicia into a trap
the coaches could be tempting Alicia to
cut Jack so they can steal him Gina I
know my team he broke my heart I don't
know what you're gonna do I just hope
anybody that has the steel feels the
same way I do right now I'll leave it at
that
yeah having three famous relatives
cutter and Jack a lot of fan folks later
and just like and to you know really
incredible guys too you know it's not
this ring oh wow he's an awesome guy
honestly when's crying we need her
makeup
[Music]
you